but about uh 15 years ago we decided
that the only way to move forward is to
focus on the pain to focus on Unsolved
issue to focus on disease that up to now
didn't have any solution and in addition
we're looking for
disease that are very common we're not
looking
for ofen rug for treatments that will be
available only for a few patient we
looking for Blockbuster a solution a
pain that is very very common and a
solution that will be able to solve this
Spain for millions of patient worldwide
every
[Music]
year shy maretzki welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you great hi M nice being here
really really great to have you here
Shai H Shai you're one of Israel's most
prominent botch entrepreneurs you've
been leading companies from engineering
to technology to a entrepr from an
entrepreneurial perspective for the last
more than 20 years with the PHD in
biotech from the techon um one of the
most prominent institutions in the world
particularly for these types of fields
and so a a lot to unpack because biotech
has took the World by a storm over the
last 20 years literally revolu ued and
revolutionizing the lives of all of us
whether we know it or not and so I'm I'm
really excited to spend the next 20
minutes with you to both go through your
own journey and to explore how this
industry has emerged and evolved over
the last 20-some years and also focusing
what you're doing today um around cell
therapy and and tissue engineering so a
lot for us to unpack Shai but but let's
start a little bit with you and and your
relationship with biotech walk me
through you know sort of what you've
done over the last 20 years okay great H
I'm active in the field of cell therapy
and tissue engineering which is a very
well defined area within the biotech or
biomed
field H I came from biotechnology I
first degree in chemical engineering I
have additional first degree in biology
and my master and PhD are in
biotechnology
in my master we're the F in my master
and PhD we're the first group ever that
have developed the ability to grow cells
in threedimensional meaning in high
level construction of cells something
much more similar to any tissue within
our
body and uh when I finished my PhD I
bought my patents you know all the
patents developed by student belong to
the academic Institute so I bought it
from the techon advancement Institute
and kept on developing cell therapy and
tissue engineering
product now in my point of view the main
thing about cell therapy and te
engineering is the fact
that it's the only therapy that really
heal people when talking about medical
process when talking about what we have
currently within the Medfield which is
Pharma and medical device it doesn't
really heal you they allow you to manage
the disease they allowed you to live
with the
disease but new tools especially in cell
therap engineering allowed you actually
to get to the roots to the base of the
damage and to get a complete and full
healing you know I I'm jumping forward
but you know a lot of time it's much
easier to see sing than talk about it
I'll show you what we are
doing this is a live a live bone a live
bone and you can see here a huge a Crazy
Bone Gap look at it next to my hand this
is a gap of over 10 cm in
lengths if a patient
losing more than 2 cm of his bone most
of the chance that he lose the arm or
leg the
current treatment for those patient are
very very hard very painful Dam very
damaging within very limited success
rate we are able to develop the ability
to take small sample of cells and I will
talk about it soon from the patient and
to grow him a new
born we are growing for the patients
that have lost born a new born from his
own cells so the body will not reject
those cells we growing it outside the
body within systems that mimic the
physiological micro environment and his
body and currently within two weeks we
can cap we are capable of growing a new
live active vial bone instead a bone
that the patient have lost and see after
we put it within the body you can
actually you cannot tell the difference
between the original bone you remember
all this is cavity and the new bone that
is feeling the cavity you're getting a
bone that identical to the original bone
from all aspects biological
chemical
immunological you're getting a new live
active tissue and when I was talking
about inducing a full and complete
healing this is exactly what I'm talking
about you're having a
gap you're losing something regardless
the reason you know it could be trauma
it could be war in Gaza it could be
infection it could be osteoporosis it
could be aging regardlessly reason we
are capable of creating a new tissue
instead the one that was lost and this
new tissue is identical to any other
tissue you're having within your body
and again we are talking about complete
healing it's not prostate it's not metal
part it's your own live active arm leg
and you can keep on walking living the
same way you did before tell me a little
bit about the what what got us here um
you know what what were the forces that
allowed us for you to show me this today
so is this something that we had 20
years ago when you started in the
industry after your PhD are is this a
are these new Technologies or new
capabilities that we've that we're
developing now where where are we at
really at this stage with with with this
type of work when I when I finish my PhD
we had the cap the capacity the ability
to grow
sales actually at the time H we didn't
know what to do with it so we can grow
sales nice great who need sales we have
enough but about H 15 years ago we
decided that the only only way to move
forward is to focus on the pain to focus
on Unsolved issue to focus on disease
that up to now didn't have any solution
and in addition we're looking for
disease that are very common we're not
looking
for often drug for treatments that will
be available only for a few patient we
are looking for Blockbuster a solution a
pain that is very very very common and a
solution that will be able to solve this
pain for millions of patient worldwide
every
year so we decided to talk about to we
knew there is a lot of pain within the
bone field again currently the only
solution for those patient is to take a
bone from one location to cut it and to
move it into the Gap location which is
very hard painful damaging process the
successories are very very low
um a lot of time the damage in the
harvesting area is even harder than the
damage in the transplant location and we
want to save this complete uh
aspect and our approach was to take a
small sample of cells from the patient
currently our raw material is a small
sample of fat tissue that we taken from
the patient you know all of us have more
than enough F tisue we're taking a small
sample
and we're growing those cells we're
isolating for the fat from the fat
tissue cells called memal cells they're
responsible us in our body for the
damage control if a patient burn cut
broke some tissue there are the cells
that will come to the damage area and
fix it nevertheless if the Gap if the
damage is too wide they cannot do it by
themselves so we sample them we grow
them in VTO in this kind of
system that mimic our body you know the
cells grow here they don't know they
really left the body they getting all
everything they need in order to
proliferate they're getting the oxygen
and the protein and the mineral and the
vitamin everything they need in order to
grow they proliferate in this
system and within about two weeks we're
getting enough bone tissue to Gap the
cavity
and up to now we have treated tens of
patient currently only in Israel but uh
I believe that this year we open Center
in the US as well
[Music]
um and we are capable of helping all
those patient incredible so um first of
all it's it's really really exciting I
mean that sounds fascinating just this
ability to take somebody who has you
know a what it sounds like a gap in in
the bone bone and to be able to extract
some some fattish should be able to grow
that bone outside the body and then and
then have a a procedure without damaging
another aspect of their body right
that's the Big H from from what I
understood um now tell me a little bit
about to from an entrepreneur's mindset
so first of all you know let's start a
few years down the line so you're this
is what you're dedicating your time to
from a from an business perspective a
commercial perspective
how what is your vision for you know
three to five years down the line how
how how big do you think this can be and
what is the impact that you think this
can have you know in terms of in terms
of reach I think that the fact currently
within the Medfield you have the Pharma
and medical device section open the
place for a third section which is
actually the cell tissue and tissue
ining field which can be as big as those
two field again because the fact that it
really induce healing and people want to
be younger
healthier and they want to heal the
disease not to manage the disease and
again we can do it and only in this
field of the bone ER reconstitution the
bone mod remodeling we're talking about
millions millions of patient in the US
every year people are losing bone all
the time and we offer them to keep the
bone to get the bone younger and active
as it was at their youth wow so do you
foresee that this type of work will not
only be to heal diseases but also to
help people with diseases that are less
that are less I guess the notable in
terms of their their their in terms of
how we think about them so almost sort
of being able to regenerate and to
become younger
internally as we grow older definitely
definitely you know the first step is to
heal damage that was already done to
treat bone cavity to treat fracture or
bone Gap that we done this is the first
stage the second stage is to prevent it
there are a numerous
reason for losing bone for example the
first reason for patient to lose bone is
osteoporosis osteoporosis is aging
disease 50% of the wom above 55 and 10%
of the male suffer from osteoporosis in
osteoporosis you lose bone mass think
about the ability within relatively very
simple process to get into those cavity
within the bone and to fill them the
bone will not break again you're
actually solving the cavity the damage
before it is done and here talking about
preventive treatment this is the next
step but the need is there the
population is there and will be more
than happy to help all those patient
absolutely
wow and so tell me a little bit about by
you know this type of field from from an
entrepreneurs perspective is this is
this only relevant for people who have
advanced degrees in in biotech are is
are there opportunities you know I'm
thinking about you know all the work
that we get to do you know growing up in
in the Cyber domain and and and and more
generic engineering work and machine
learning you know what would it take for
somebody who's really interested in this
field and wants to have a positive
impact be able to come and and work in
the domain of of Biotech today actually
one of the things that is very important
not in the biotech but in our field of
cell thue engineering is the fact that
it's combined Knowledge from variet your
field in my company located in hia
Israel you have tens of patient tens of
PhD from different field of course you
will find the biology people and the
biotechnology people but you will also
we find
clinician and people coming for
mechanical engineering from material
from chemistry from H software and
Hardware because we are talking about
creating system complete
live system that should be supported
from all aspect so you need people
coming from variety of field variety of
knowledge and you need to combine all of
them together in order to get this very
unique uh abilities to mimic the body to
control the growth and to get exactly
what you want at very short time and
reasonable cost right and so that it
sounds like those that are coming from
more traditional machine learning
backgrounds engineering backgrounds
there are there are definitely
opportunities there as well definitely
AI all all over what what's been your
personal experience over the last 20
years so so I understand what you're
doing today and it sounds extremely
exciting you you've had the opportunity
of working in multiple in in in multiple
capacities in this field what what how
has your own experience changed over
time either due to public perception
awareness excitement around the industry
what what's been evolving over the last
20 years I think when when we started
working with IND this field of cell
therapy of tissue
engineering actually it was sounds like
sense fiction nobody believe it's doable
you know it was at some point in the
future someone will be able to do
it uh even when we started bonus bi
group about 12 years ago what we had is
a few mil who is Tiny Bone of 5 mm in
size
and today we have t of patient
working Among Us and the tisue was
created in
vitto and you have people that were in a
wheelchair for years started working
again because we're able to grow their
newborn you know currently in Israel
because of 7th October and the war you
have many young people that have lost
tissues and we are more than happy we
opened addition a medical center in the
sou of Israel in order to be able to
help all those people in the South and
to help them to prevent
imputation of the arms or leg that were
damage due to the situation looking you
know more
broadly you know you're you're
dedicating your life basically to this
Mission it sounds like you've been doing
this ever since your Academia and
obviously you're your 12 years into this
this specific journey and then it sounds
like the passion is just is just
starting but what what really is your is
your main driver here so if you look at
sort of your big
motivations I I think the fact that we
are doing thing that nobody nobody did
it before we are the first and only one
having the ability to grow those tissues
you know just this January there was the
big Conference of advanced therapy and
we
won the the reward for the most
in Innovative group in the world within
this field nobody else does it and the
fact that we are capable of growing
we're starting with bone but bone is
only the beginning we are working other
tissue as well and we are working other
organ in parallel and our goal is to be
able to
supply replace part for
all H and we're on the way well I can
only imagine a a world in which H we all
get to be a to be healed and uh through
through the work of of bonus by a group
and and what you're doing and it sounds
like a it's not just a a journey for for
the short term but it's a it's
definitely Journey for the long term and
it sounds like you have a you know a
vision for how the technology you're
building and the Innovations you're
doing are going to be implemented at
large scales and and impact people's
lives dramatically you you talked before
about the wheelchair examp example and
then I can only imagine the impact this
this can have on one person and how
life-changing it can be so I can only
imagine then if you get a chance to
multiply it h best of luck with the
expansion Shai it sounds like you're
this is a very important year and an
important timing and so wishing you best
of luck I'm sure that we're all rooting
for you H so important and thank you
very much for
everything thank you very much pleasure
bye-bye bye
[Music]